we should kill them
we can murder the man but what about the
movement brother
martyrs tend to have a long half-life
hey guys pete here today i'm going to be
talking about the new official trailer
that just came out for the apple tv
series based on isaac asimov's classic
sci-fi series foundation there isn't a
ton of brand new footage in it there are
a couple of things and i do think we get
a better idea of what to expect from the
series overall for a spoiler warning as
someone who's read all of asimov's
foundation series plus the robots and
empire books i will be referring to
those but i won't be giving away any
spoilers about the big twists or how
things end i'll just be sticking to
background information to give you a
better idea of what we can expect and
with that out of the way let's get into
it
the first two episodes of foundation
will be airing in about a month on
friday september 24th and then the
additional episodes will air weekly as
far as what the official trailer shows
us i think there's a few things going on
here first the core of the beginning of
the original trilogy that centers around
harry selden and galdornik is there
in case you've never read any of the
original stories i'll give you the brief
rundown harry selden who's played by
jared harris here has developed
psycho-history a mathematical
statistical science that incorporates
history psychology and sociology to
predict future events based on the
behaviors of large populations of people
in his work he's discovered that the
galactic empire which has ruled for more
than 10 000 years will fall and then
that's going to be followed by a long
period of chaos
because the ruling class doesn't want to
give up their power it's in their
interest not to believe him and
generally they don't want to hear about
his predictions
as far as the collapse things are too
far along to stop it selden's plan is to
create the foundation in an effort to
shorten the inner regnum and help usher
in the new galactic empire in the next
1000 years this would be a big
improvement over the 30 000 years of
chaos that was originally predicted he's
recruited gal dornick a mathematician
from a provincial world to help
implement the psycho-historian's plan
most of what you've seen in the teasers
between harry and gal is taken directly
from the first chapter of the book
foundation and it's expanded on in this
official trailer it's a big deal for gal
or anyone from her planet to visit
trantor to even travel there and she's
got a job and when she arrives to work
for this famous mathematician she finds
out that his work isn't theoretical that
psycho history is real where it looks
like they've changed this some is that
they're just going to give us more
information about what happened both of
these characters only show up at the
beginning and there's a 50 year time
jump that happens right after some of
this could be from that time and then
some of it will likely be there to make
it work better as a tv drama and i'll
come back to that in a minute the second
thing that jumps right out at you is
that there is a lot of action sequences
and i think it's worth mentioning that
they look pretty amazing ships in orbit
planets under attack people charging
across what look like battlefields
firing weapons it all gives you the
impression that this is a high-paced
series that's filled with intense
battles and impressive set pieces the
book series isn't known for this kind of
stuff in fact the lack of action is one
of the things that made it seem like it
would be a hard adaptation
some of what you see in the trailer may
be pulling from things that happen off
screen in the books but even if that's
the case it looks like there'll be a lot
more of a focus on that and we'll have
to wait and see how that all works out
the third thing that stands out is that
there are some things here that seem to
be pulled from the prequels although to
me it looks like they're pulling them
forward in the timeline so that they
occur at the same time as the events of
the beginning of the original trilogy
one thing i wasn't sure about when the
last teaser came out was who the actor
alfred enoch was playing since then it's
been confirmed that he's playing rach
selden he plays a big role in the
prequels he was a street kid that harry
came across in some of his adventures on
trantor and then became his adoptive son
but he would have been a lot older by
the time galdornik arrived because at
the end of the prequels 40 years had
passed since harry first met the 12 year
old rach he grew up he got married and
gave harry two grandchildren it doesn't
look like that's going to be the case in
the show and so now let's look at
everything else that stands out as being
new in this official trailer because
part of it is related to him it opens
with a new overhead shot of galdornik's
home planet of synax from this it looks
like it's a planet covered with water
there's several new quick shots of gal
transitioning to life on trantor and in
those it looks like there's going to be
a connection between her and rach they
do share a lot of scenes in the previous
teasers it looked like he was showing
her around but here it looks like
there's a relationship developing you
see them in a scene where she has her
head on his shoulder and says this is
the plan and then you see them kiss that
doesn't really create any problems in
relation to the original story but it
might have implications down the road
without getting into spoilers that might
be part of the reason that harry selden
sticks around in the story for a while
longer which doesn't seem like it'll be
a problem considering most people love
jared harris
another brand new sequence is this one
where the emperor is out there amongst
the people things look pretty destroyed
and that's probably related to one of
the battle scenes that are sprinkled
throughout the trailer in the voice over
you hear the clone emperors talking
about what you presume is harry seldon
and the psycho historians brother dusk
says we should kill them and brother day
responds we can murder the man but what
about the movement brother martyrs tend
to have a long half-life this seems to
be building off what he was saying in
the second teaser that harry had a mast
of following and that there are people
out there that hinge their hopes on
every word that seldon utters so it does
seem like the tension will be increased
in the lead up to the encyclopedist
leaving trantor for terminus and we do
get our first mentions of that in the
voice over here harry says many years
from now if humanity is going to climb
from the ashes the coming generations
will need the knowledge to build upon a
foundation gal continues we must
preserve only the most essential pieces
of civilization deciding what is
remembered what is forgotten that's the
setup for what's to come for when the
series transitions to terminus and it
focuses on the mayor salver hardin now
in my last video i talked more about the
clone situation how that keeps lee pace
in the series longer and about the
changes for the vault and salver harden
so if you haven't seen that you should
check out that video for more
information on those two things in this
trailer we do get a couple of new shots
with salvor at the vault we see her
reaching out to it at one point and in
another it looks like she asks it what's
the plan and then there's this shot of
her in a suit out in the vacuum there's
what looks like a spin station or a ship
and a lot of asteroids which could be
debris i have no idea what's going on
here it doesn't remind me of anything
that happens in harden's parts in the
book and it makes me wonder if they're
combining some characters and events
while rearranging the timeline
it looks kind of cool though and it does
seem to indicate that we'll be jumping
ahead at least 50 years in the first
season
visually this all looks great there's
nothing in this official trailer that's
made me change my mind i'm still feeling
somewhat optimistic about this
i don't think expanding the time we
spend with harry and gal after she
arrives i don't think that sounds like a
bad thing adding some action sequences
always seemed like it might be essential
to attracting a wider audience i'm
definitely in the club that enjoys the
books as they are but can also see that
there are some things that might not
work so well for television in my
thinking a one-to-one adaptation would
be terribly boring for people who hadn't
read the books and it probably wouldn't
get made
however i'm drawn to stories for the
ideas i don't consume a lot of
action-based entertainment and so i hope
they can strike a balance nothing wrong
with tension and some kick-ass stuff to
get the blood pumping if it's done well
but it needs to not overshadow what was
good about these stories in the first
place i don't feel the need to get
worried about it at this point their
trailers of course they're gonna
showcase the most visually stimulating
stuff they need to bring people in
in the trailer breakdown that david s
goyer made where he talks about some of
the challenges he mentions that they
really wanted to take this story that
had fantastic big ideas and then make it
work for tv and a big challenge was how
are they going to make it emotional how
could they make it intimate and we'll
see if they're able to pull that off
another challenge i mentioned is how it
moves through time and this was
addressed in a recent article with
hollywood reporter where he says that he
figured out a way to have some of the
characters extend their life spans about
six characters will continue from season
to season from century to century so
it's half anthology half continuing
story in the original there's two
characters who stay in the story through
the generations in different ways cleon
the clone emperor would be the third
presuming he only counts as one and if
six is the right number then that leaves
three more it makes me wonder seeing all
these different tanks and people being
submerged if there won't be suspended
animation or hibernation involved the
main characters from this season
sticking around to come back later
according to the plan that wouldn't be a
huge stretch and i suppose it's too much
to get into right now but i would just
hope to see that they don't diminish the
way people react to the plan and
experience the future crises and that
seems like a good place to leave things
i'll probably think about this some more
and then do a predictions type of video
before the first episode comes out until
then let me know what you think about
the trailer in the comments and what
you're hoping to see in the series i'm
down if you want to talk book spoilers
just please mark those accordingly we
don't want to spoil future plot points
for people who haven't read the books
i'm really curious to see how they use
ado demmersell in this first season and
if there's going to be any surprises
with that please like this video if you
enjoyed it please do check out my other
foundation videos if you haven't seen
them please subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already and let me know if
you have any questions thanks for
watching i'll talk to you soon